esta vez nos preguntan para qué
intervalos la función f es decreciente y
tenemos aquí a la función fx igual a
equis elevado a la sexta potencia menos
tres veces x elevado a la quinta
potencia y esta vez vamos a hacerlo pero
sin graficar que igual a fx así que la
forma de hacer esto es explicarnos en la
derivada de f con respecto a x y verza
en qué momento esa derivada es menor que
cero si la razón de cambios de f con
respecto a x es menor que cero entonces
en esos intervalos
mi función original este de aquí va a
estar decreciendo muy bien qué te parece
si primero tomamos la derivada y la
derivada texto con respecto a x quién va
a ser f prima de x va a ser igual y
bueno es simplemente aplicar la regla de
la potencia así que estos 6 los vamos a
bajar me va a quedar
x elevado a la quinta potencia 6 menos
15 ya esto le vamos a quitar y otra vez
este 5 lo vamos a multiplicar por este
menos 3 lo cual nos va a dar menos 15 x
elevado a la cuarta potencia 5 - 1 es 4
muy bien y queremos saber en qué momento
estuve aquí es menor que cero para que
intervalos 6x quinta menos 15 x elevado
a la cuarta potencia esto sea menor que
es cero y bueno lo primero que se me
ocurre es que podemos factorizar un x
elevado a la cuarta potencia de hecho un
3x elevado a la cuarta potencia 3x
elevado a la cuarta potencia que
multiplica a quien bueno primero va a
multiplicar a 2 x 2 x por 3x elevado a
la cuarta potencia me quedan tres por 12
elevado a la quinta potencia menos 5 lo
hice bien veamos 3x elevado a la cuarta
potencia por 12 x me quedan 6 x a la
quinta potencia menos 3 por 5 es 15 x
elevado a la cuarta potencia muy bien
esto quiero que sea menor que cero y
ahora lo que vamos a hacer es fijarnos
cuando esto es menor que cero porque si
tenemos el producto de todos cosas y
queremos que ese producto sea negativo
entonces sólo hay dos formas de que esto
pase ya sea que el primero sea positivo
y el segundo sea negativo cuando ves que
el primero sea negativo y el segundo
positivo así que vamos a escribirlo
déjame cambiar de color o 3x elevado a
la cuarta potencia es menor que cero y a
su vez
x menos 5 esto es mayor que 0 este es
uno de los casos o el otro de los casos
lo voy a poner con este color el otro de
los casos serían de 3x elevado a la
cuarta potencia sea mayor que 0 y a su
vez se cumplan que 2x menos 5 esto sea
menor que cero espera menor que es cero
muy bien
así que veamos 3x a la cuarta menor que
cero
eso suena medio mal porque si dividimos
todo entre tres me quedaría que x a la
cuarta tendría que ser menor que cero y
existe alguna forma para que algo
elevado a la cuarta potencia sea menor
que cero no si suponemos que trabajamos
con números reales entonces todo el
número real elevado a una potencia par
va a ser mayor o igual a cero así que de
hecho esto es imposible que algo elevado
a la cuarta potencia sea menor que cero
esto nunca va a pasar así que déjenme
tachar todo este primer caso todo este
primer caso no va a suceder esto porque
3x a la cuarta esto no puede ser menor
que cero muy bien entonces me queda que
el segundo caso es tener 3x a la cuarta
mayor que 0 y 2 x 5 menor que cero bueno
3 x a la cuarta mayor que será esto es
siempre cierto lo que vamos a ver bueno
es siempre cierto
x sea distinto de 0 déjame ponerlo
mientras x no sea 0 porque en este caso
3x elevado a la cuarta potencial sería 0
si x es negativa no importa porque al
elevarla a la cuarta potencia nos dará
algo positivo y bueno veamos qué dice la
segunda desigualdad 2x menos 5 es menor
que cero eso quiere decir que 2x tiene
que ser menor que 5 si sumamos 5 de
ambos lados o que x es menor que cinco
medios que 5 medios estamos dividiendo
todo entre 2 entonces todos los valores
menores a 5 medios y que sean distintos
de 0 recuerda que aquí hay una y que se
cumplan ambas restricciones nos va a dar
una función creciente y si queremos
escribir esto como un intervalo podemos
decir que x tiene que ser menor que cero
es decir todos los valores negativos o
equis tienen que estar en 3
y cinco medios x tiene que estar entre 0
y 5 medios y esta de aquí sería mi
respuesta correcta x menor que cero son
todos los valores negativos y observa
que no estamos tomándonos al 0 lo
quitamos y después nos tomamos todo lo
que está entre 0 y 5 medios y recuerda
lo único que dicen es ver donde nuestra
primera derivada está de aquí era
negativa porque si la primera del bada
efe prima de x es menor que cero
entonces la razón de cambio dt con
respecto a x es negativa lo que quiere
decir que se va a hacer decreciente en s